there's a single definition of success
look at yourself in a mirror in the
evening and wonder if you disappoint the
person you were at 18
right before
people get corrupted by life let him or
her be the only judge
not your reputation not your wealth not
your standing in a community not the
decorations on your laypal
if you do not feel ashamed
then you are successful
all other definitions of success
are modern constructions fragile modern
constructions
the ancient Greeks definition of success
was to have had a heroic death
but as we live in a less martial Society
we can adapt our definition of success
as having taken a heroic route for the
benefits of the collective
as narrowly or broadly defined as you
want
so long as it's someone else
for example secret societies have the
rule of omo donori
you're as good as what you do to other
members
so virtue is inseparable from Courage
so he had to take some risks personal
financial whatever for the sake of
others that's success that's honor
it can be helping the local municipality
for example I'm giving a hint here or
with the more micro
the less abstract
the better
so success requires absence of fragility
I've seen billionaires
terrified of journalists
wealthy people who felt crushed
because their brother-in-law got very
rich
academics with Nobel who were scared of
comments on the web
the higher you go
the worse the fall for almost all people
have met external not internal success
came with an increase in fragility
and heightened state of insecurity
the worst are those former something
types with four page CV
who after leaving office
and addicted to the attention
of servile bureaucrats
find themselves discarded it's as if you
went home one evening to discover that
someone suddenly unempted your house of
all this furniture
self-respect on the other hand is robust
that's the approach of the stoic school
so I've seen robust people in my Village
immune
who were proud of being you know local
citizens you know liked by the community
the wake up happy and go to bed happy
or Russian mathematicians who during the
difficult post-soviet period
were proud of making 200 a month
and did work that was appreciated by 20
people and considered that showing
was decorations or accepting Awards
that was a sign of weakness and lack of
confidence in one's own contribution
and believe it or not some wealthy
people are robust but you just don't
hear about them because they're not
socialized
they live next door and they drink
baladi not verifico
do not read newspapers do not follow
the news in any way or form
to be convinced go to the library and
try to read last year's newspaper
okay and that will convince you
second thing
something is nonsense
you say it and you say it out loud
you'll be harmed a little bit but be
anti-fasile in the long run people who
need to trust you will trust you
when I was still an obscure author
I walked out of the studio
Bloomberg Radio because the interviewers
was they were saying nonsense so I just
walked out
people told me you'll never have any
coverage by Bloomberg ever again I said
okay
two years later they had a cover story
on me okay
so if you see nonsense say it and say it
loud
tweet the doorman
with a lot of respect
okay more than if you were the boss the
boss can go down not the doorman
if something is boring avoid it
except of course
taxes and visits to your mother-in-law
okay other than these avoid everything
boring
now what was the idea of having a
rabbi's code
it was not eye for eye
[Music]
eyes for eye limiting damages you know
and making things ballast no
it was that you cannot walk away from
risks you've created for others
you should own your risks that's the
idea of Hammurabi's growth you cannot
have civilized society unless those who
create risks
aren't also aware of the risk but let's
first look at it from a moral standpoint
okay you've heard of the Golden Rule do
unto others what you want them to do to
you
which I in fact I
find a little intrusive because say I
like raw Lebanese meat lovers could be
I'm not going to force you to eat it all
right so
there's actually and say I'm a
bureaucrat and and like this kind of
stuff I'm not force you there is a much
more robust silver rule don't do to
others what you don't want to do to you
and and effectively you can have
civilization without the silver rule
people ask me uh what should I be doing
okay
um 20 and uh you know go somewhere start
a business take risks now because
everybody wants to work for a GMO to
improve the world as you end up like the
UN offices
manufacturing problems just so you hire
more staff who fly a business class and
have an apartment in Geneva that kind of
stuff
start a business because we're tired of
people who want to work for ngos okay
start a business create jobs for others
okay and do not rent seek do not be in
rent seeking
have some skin in the game
just like you know your your
grandparents probably Grant one of your
grandfathers was at age 18 disembarking
in Normandy they took a lot of risk
these kids or 18 year old
okay it takes some risk starting
business
thanks because of you I started doing
dead lifting
game yeah so skin in the game let me
tell you something about deadlifting I
was uh no I was I had this motto skin
and again that you should never tell
people what they should be doing you
should tell them what you're doing okay
and I had the back injury when I was
writing anti-fragile about seven years
ago and I cured it by the dead lifting
so and then I started discovering the
value of intense heavy weight on on
humans like the bone stuff like that and
and the reason I talk about my own
deadlifting is only to say that after in
the game I'm telling you I had the
injuries of a deadlifter I'm telling you
so I bear the risk of my advice
I always like Nasim talib's framing on
this where he said with my family I'm a
communist with my close friends I'm a
socialist uh you know at my state level
politics I'm a Democrat at you know
higher levels I'm a I'm a Republican and
at the federal level I'm a Libertarian
right so basically the larger the group
of people you have mass together who
have different interests the less trust
there is the more cheating there is the
better the incentives have to be aligned
the better the system has to work the
more you go towards capitalism the
smaller the group you're in you're in a
kibbetts you're in your commune you're
in your house you're in your tribe by
all means be a socialist with my aunts
with my brother with my cousins with my
uncles with my mom but yeah family I'm a
socialist that's the right way to live a
loving happy Integrated Life yes but
when you're dealing with strangers I
mean you want to be a real socialist
great open all your doors and windows
tomorrow please everybody come take what
you want see how that works out
and there are a lot of rules in my book
so I'm going to end up with No No's the
things to avoid completely
muscles without strength
friendship without trust
opinion without risk
change without Aesthetics
age without values
food without nourishment
power without fairness
facts without rigor
degrees without iridition
militarism without fortitude
progress without civilization
complication without depth
fluency without content
and most of all religion without
tolerance thank you